major issues right now on the road yeah
now the good news if there is any is
that the freeways are okay but we have
two major streets completely closed by
fatal crashes this one is at flamingo
just around arville so flamingo is
completely closed between arville and
valley view here's a live picture there
are metro police this is flamingo
eastbound this is north and southbound
arvel east bounders are being detoured
onto north arville a better way to get
around is to completely avoid flamingo
take decatur down to trop or up to
spring mountain or d.i no word on how
long flamingo is going to be closed but
that's not it there is a second fatal
auto pedestrian crash this one actually
happened first about three o'clock this
morning rainbow completely closed
between sahara and d.i here's a live
picture here these are the southbounders
being detoured into residential
neighborhoods northbounders the same
thing again you can skip rainbow and go
east over to jones or west over to
buffalo two fatal crashes this morning
one closing flamingo at arville the
second closing rainbow between sahara
and d.i mean